And oh, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters doing a series here on different mechanisms of cancer and at this presentation
We're going to talk about helicobacter pylori, a long name you probably know it by each pylori
Each pylori is a major cause of cancer
It is what each pylori is is a bacteria looks like this or this presentation this picture there
It's a gram-negative bacteria that's the classification of bacteria. It is it falls under
Many of the gram-negative bacteria could act similar to a virus and that's what we're going to explain in this video here
Viruses basically reproduce not extracellularity, but they reproduce intracellularity
bacteria mainly stay outside of the cell, that's why the antibiotics can kill bacteria
and antibiotics cannot kill viruses. So if you have a viral infection in antibiotic is useless because the virus is hiding inside the cell
whereas you have a bacterial infection used in antibiotic it kills it quite randomly
except for a few of the bacteria some of the gram-negative bacteria, H-pylori
but by the way, Lyme disease, the Borrelia, Bergenorphy bacteria, also is in the gram-negative bacteria family
and the reason why Lyme disease is so horrible is that it has the ability to go inside the cell and hide
so that it ain't about a kid kill that after a certain stage as well
so that's what makes H-pylori so sneaky and so bad
so what it does, it has these little flagella on the back of its body and either side of the body
and that's what helps it move around within the bloodstream and within the extracellular spaces
also although on this slide it has these things called lipopolysaccharides that are pink, that big word and pink
lipopolysaccharides, all of the gram-negative bacteria have that extra layer in its cell membrane
called the lipopolysaccharide. The bad thing about lipopolysaccharides is that they become liberated
and become what is known as an endotoxin when you destroy the bacteria
so this is why you can have such a negative reaction or a herx reaction
when you effectively kill the bacteria because it liberates these lipopolysaccharides that your body reacts to from an immune response
so you end up with a hyperabute response to the particles of dead cells, specifically these lipopolysaccharides
so I said that gram-negative bacteria and one of the bad things about them is some of them could get inside of a cell
so this picture shows on the outside of a host cell affected receptor sites on the host cell
it stimulates an immune response that is good but it can stimulate a hyperabute response
it can be a huge player as far as an antigen goes, an illicitated, an autoimmune disease as well
the other thing with cancer with H. Pylori is that it reduces the cell's ability to go through apoptosis
and if you have not listened to my series on apoptosis I'll challenge you to do that
apoptosis is the normal program cell death mechanism that is broken on every cancer patient in order for you to have cancer
you have to have a broken apoptotic cycle that has to have started at least with one cell
so here's a picture of a normal virus life cycle, the virus does not replicate outside of a cell, a host cell
the virus goes inside the cell and starts to replicate inside the cell it's immune to any antibiotic use
it's immune to your immune system use
typically when a virus infiltrates a cell it has the cell has the ability to notify the immune system that it's been infiltrated by an enemy
it puts up these little markers on the outside of the cell that provide telly macrophages that there's a bad guy inside the cell
so the macrophage will literally devour the entire cell and thereby kill the virus that's how your body gets up
killy viruses, it sacrifices self cells in the process to kill the virus
because otherwise the virus will continue to replicate goes outside the cell, goes inside another cell
does the same thing replicates and replicates, breaks out of that cell, goes to another cell and it just becomes a nasty thing
the viruses that are difficult to kill, you can see why
H. Pylora and Lyme disease, the burgodorphine bacteria, have the ability to once they go inside the cell they disable
that membrane marker from telling the immune system that it has been infiltrated pretty sneaky
so whereas viruses go inside the cell the cell actually gives off a marker to tell a macrophage a white blood cell that it's been infiltrated
so the white blood cell could engulf the entire cell and kill it
when the gram negative bacteria go inside the cell they disable that marker so that there's no indication
by the immune system that that cell has been compromised and that bad things can happen
this bacteria could reproduce inside that cell and go extra cellular and do it to another cell
in the case of Lyme disease, in the case of H. Pylora I can even be worse
H. Pylora I can disrupt the apoptotic cycle so apoptosis is controlled by a series of different cascade mechanisms within the cell
the most important are called the Caspase system
the Caspase system is what turns on the cell death program
H. Pylora interrupts the Caspase system
so that that cell doesn't go through apoptosis and stays alive so that the H. Pylora could replicate
so H. Pylora's purpose is self-survival so we'll interrupt the neural apoptosis cycle so that we can stay alive
and replicate inside the cell safely away from the immune response, away from maybe a medication use of an antibiotic
and we'll stay alive. Well the problem is is you're keeping that cell alive with a broken apoptotic cycle
if it affects the DNA of the replication cycle now you have cancer
so what cancer is is a broken apoptotic cycle the cell is not died
and a broken replication cycle the cell is known as a rapid replication state
it could all be caused by H. Pylora
if you look at the World Health Organization you'll see that H. Pylora is the number one cause of stomach cancer worldwide
it's a very common cause of esophageal and colon cancer, prostate cancer and other cancers as well
so it's a nasty player it's one of the top five causes of heart disease
as it gets in underneath the endothelial layer which is the skeet of the inside of the vessels
so summarize this up it's acts like a virus it goes inside the cell it inhibits its apoptosis
so the cell doesn't die it sets you up for cancer so we want to kill this thing
H. Pylora is a bad guy so first of all how does it into your body?
H. Pylora is basically a food board or early board bacteria
you could get it from kissing somebody else it has it you could get it from their saliva
you'll get it from someone who prepared food basically you can't live your life without being exposed to H. Pylora
maybe multiple times a year maybe multiple times a week
H. Pylora is ubiquitous there was a few articles out of the AMA and British Journal of Medicine a few years ago
that said conservatively over 50% of the world's population have an undiagnosed, undiagnosed H. Pylora infection
it is everywhere it's ubiquitous there's no hiding and running from H. Pylora
now understand if you have healthy H. C. L. production by your stomach and healthy digestive enzymes
in your duodenum your first part of your intestines you will never get it you will never get sick from it
you will be exposed to it but your immune system will kill it off right away
H. Pylora goes into your stomach first and if you have adequate hydrochloric acid production by your stomach cells
it will be killed and you will have no issue with it
so it acts like a virus that infiltrates itself it can break down apoptosis and block that
but it starts in your stomach now also if you've never heard of H. Pylora you probably heard of it
in its connection to stomach ulcers because it is the cause of stomach ulcers
if you're lucky so if you're lucky you get a stomach ulcer you get taken in a biotic you kill the H. Pylora
most of the time you don't get a stomach ulcer it infiltrates the stomach it gets out into the bloodstream
and it spreads around and it could cause all sorts of things like heart disease and cancer
so you never do you had it so you just have H. Pylora infection and undiagnosed H. Pylora infection for 3, 10, 15, 20 years
and you ended up with heart disease or cancer not a good thing
so how do you kill it?
well if you have it in the acute stage similar to lime you could kill it with an antibiotic
so it's not yet infiltrated to cell it's still in the stomach it's just destroyed stomach cells
and antibiotic is the first order of choice the problem is is that patients that come to me they have cancer
it's too late for antibiotics antibiotics are not going to work you have to use some natural antibiotics
because antibiotics will not get in the cell and they will kill it when it goes extracellular
it can't be on low term antibiotics especially if you have cancer it's going to break down
your rest of your immune system and it's just a good thing to do so you have to use some natural antibiotics
so there are some good natural antibiotic things that help with killing H. Pylora
we use a lot of medicinal mushroom issues with H. Pylora it works very very well to kill the H. Pylora
probiotics are really important to help prevent H. Pylora and remember H. Pylora is a bacteria
so all bacteria and all viruses are competitive they are opportunistic
so if you can provide your body with other competing good bacteria and good viruses and good flora
you're going to prevent infiltration and nasty things so using probiotics creating your own probiotics by drinking water
key for things are really a great way to go to help prevent H. Pylora issues
you also want to do things if you already know you have cancer to stimulate
cast based function, remember it's the cast based system that's the system, the internal system of mechanism that pushes the apoptotic program
that is the intrinsic apoptotic cycle of the cell and you do that with medicinal mushrooms again
so you can take a hint that I really like medicinal mushrooms they work quite well to kill H. Pylora and to push the cast based system
Burberry is also been found to do wonders in helping push the cast based system and help kill H. Pylora
so that is a favorite of mine to make sure that you are using enzymes on a regular basis
if you have anybody with H. Pylora in your household you basically have to treat the whole house so it just prevent H. Pylora
you got to make sure you have healthy H. Pylora in your stomach healthy enzymes in your gut I like the U.S. enzymes brand that's a fermented enzyme
it works much better I also like zypan that's a standard process product and other H. Pylora products you can get just in your local store
you take that only with your food and this is your using enzymes these enzymes solely as a digestive enzymes
so you are taking it with a food Burberry is a good product to take on a regular basis and we use our own blend
personal blend of medicinal mushrooms this immune to totals another product that you can actually get online
so hope this helps there's a lot of information online if you want to search for details and studies on H. Pylora and cancer
it's not it's not anything you've heard about up to this point it's because your doctor just hasn't told you about it
there's just tons and tons of research on this all right I hope this helps talk to you soon